you mentioned that you love the writings
of Sarah yeah yeah he's he's not only a
great mathematician but he's a great
Expositor as well have you written a
book by the way a textbook
too lazy no is there something that you
wish other people who write textbooks
would adopt from Sarah
well if they could adopt his he has a
somehow a very clear writing style
um
he puts in all details even if they seem
to be unnecessary and for example
um so
I mean all too often authors will miss
out details that they they think are
obvious and maybe are obvious if you're
an expert but
throw you if you're a beginner says the
tendency to put in
details even if they seem a little bit
obvious and boring which is very useful
if they turn out to be
not as obvious and boring as the author
thinks so you prefer over explain to me
because I can always skip Pages if I
don't you can always yeah if if you over
explain that the reader can always skip
it